TV is a whole lot better than it used to be.
Over the past decade or so, so-called "prestige
TV" has offered audiences superb acting, cinematic
style, unpredictable storylines, and an epic
scope never before seen on the small screen.
Many of these shows are serious, sometimes
devastating dramas with important things to
say.
But even brilliant productions like these
crank out plenty of ridiculous and hilarious
bloopers and outtakes.
Breaking Bad
Child actors are unpredictable.
And the younger they are, the more unpredictable
they can be.
But productions only have a limited time each
day to use babies, so they can't wait around
for when the baby "feels" like acting, especially
since they don't really know they're acting.
Nor do they care.
Take this Breaking Bad outtake, for example,
in which the infant playing Holly White makes
some very interesting "choices" for her character
É
"The kids, they, they, they are safe.
Of course they are."
"I don't think she feels very safe."
Game of Thrones
In this blooper from HBO's fantasy epic Game
of Thrones, Kit Harington plays the corpse
of Jon Snow, his body laid out on a table
for what will ultimately be his spooky resurrection
from the dead.
Snow is supposed to be naked in this scene,
with only a modest, genital-concealing garment
preventing everyone on set from seeing Little
Jon É
Deadwood
So many gag reels consist of actors forgetting
their lines and swearing up a storm.
But what happens on a show like HBO's gritty
western Deadwood, in which half of the dialogue
is already swearing?
The actors simply burst into song.
Or at least that's what happens when apparent
Rolling Stones fan Ian McShane can't remember
what comes after a line that includes the
words "start me" É
"Don't start me É Don't start me?
Oh!
'Start me up!
And you start me up, you whip me up, you put
me down É'"
Sons of Anarchy
There's a lot of platonic male-on-male affection
on Sons of Anarchy, especially in the form
of back-slapping bro hugs.
But while shooting one of the show's many
action sequences, actor Ryan Hurst overestimates
how far he needs to move and winds up unusually
close to his fellow gun-toting, cover-seeking
costar Charlie Hunnam É
"What do you want for Christmas?"
Hannibal
Bryan Fuller's artfully gory television adaptation
of Thomas Harris' Hannibal Lecter novels featured
many scenes of its central cannibalistic serial
killer intricately preparing gourmet meals
in his beautiful kitchen.
A lot of that was likely achieved through
the magic of editing, because in this blooper,
actor Mads Mikkelsen can't quite master the
show-offy knife skills that would be second
nature to the character ...
"...invented in the 19th century."
Criminal Minds
Despite the gruesome subject matter of Criminal
Minds, it looks like the cast and crew keep
things pretty light and loose on set.
He's no longer with the show, but Thomas Gibson
seemed to have a pretty good time while he
was starring on the long-running CBS crime
procedural Ñ like the time it took him a
comically long time to put a pair of rubber
gloves on É
"Y'know, your prostate is the, about the right
size for a man your age."
Law & Order: SVU
When you're making a long-running crime series
about the most appalling of crimes, allowing
yourself to laugh here and there on set is
a good way for actors to cope with the depressing
material.
Case in point: former Law & Order:SVU star
Christopher Meloni can't get over how funny
it isÑand how utterly creepy he soundsÑto
ask a suspect for something rather unusual
"Would you mind if we took a DNA swab from
inside your mouth?
Even I felt creepy."
"Would you mind if we took a DNA swab from
inside your mouth?
It'll help us Ñ Even I, I felt creepy again."
ER
The hit NBC hospital drama ER made George
Clooney a superstar, and not long after, he
became one of the biggest movie stars on the
planet.
He also had a unique way of coming up with
some dialogue in the event that he forgot
a line while filming the incredibly fast-paced
show É
"We're gonna try something.
I want you to close your eyes, I want you
to think of Ñ Think of me, with no clothes
on."
"Would you just shut up and kiss me?"
"Kiss me!"
Orphan Black
Tatiana Maslany plays many different clones
on Orphan Black, but they're all pretty different.
For example, Alison Hendrix is a high-strung
Type-A kind of person, Sarah Manning is a
self-sufficient and streetwise rogue, and
the Ukrainian clone Helena always seems to
have really bad things happen to her.
In this scene, there's a scorpion that's supposed
to be crawling all over Helena, but Maslany
just can't keep it together É
"Inside of É"
"It was perfect."
"That was so good!"
"So good!"
"I'm so sorry."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!